let's bring out Sara shall we she's an
actress and comedian who hosts a weekly
talk show on Thursdays on Hulu it's
amazing I love it it's called
I Love You America please welcome
America's girlfriend they wish Sarah
Silverman
[Applause]
this is a very one-sided panel but you
know what I was saying about the 10
commandments right you've made that joke
- oh is that what just a big reaction
was because I was getting my hair
tweaked in ago what do you say what he
said and there's a guy next to me goes
will they rerun it all week it doesn't
[ __ ] help me now - I love your show
first of all I love that you love
America and you really do you're not
saying yeah you really do you're not
faking it yeah I love it that's why I
want it to be the best you know you're
first way it's such a great show because
I find it I love it sets as two-hybrid
you know that you do a lot of different
things I think this is show you were
always meant to do I love the white guy
at the desk bit it's just he's got a
great arc coming up it's basically the
tell them what that is it's just very
funny the concept oh well you know the
show is basically I like to think of it
as like an r-rated kid's show for adults
it's wit that's based on the tenets of
my hero Mister Rogers if it's
mentionable it's manageable and but like
we can say and and so when things get a
little far out because you know we like
our night time TV to be comfortable like
for me it's Law & Order I like it it I
know it I I need to fall asleep to the
the sounds of softcore murderer ripped
from the headlines of 19
other people it's late-night talk show
we have a white guy at a desk we can
always go to and things are a little too
far out and he'll be like well that just
yeah he's great but we've had a falling
out and for that part but it basically
follows the arc of the disenfranchised
white male and we love him so it's gonna
be interesting I think so I saw the
first for the fifth year there's a fifth
one is that the debt was that last night
Oh 1 2 3 4 5 yeah what's that about well
actually it's about fear in how we can
be manipulated by fear I say well one
thing I've learned from doing this show
you know I'm not turning towards you
because backstage I go don't twist
towards him
we want our guests to feel natural
that's that's what yeah I'm actually I'm
off my line - I'm supposed to be like
this
and I love that you visit people so
you're doing the one thing wait I never
get the right question I want to say
what was the question what's the favor
right I talk about fear so what I've
learned doing this show is that people
don't change from facts you can throw
facts in their faces and pull numbers
and it doesn't change people's beliefs
and it's we're the same way we are all
this way what changes people are their
feelings right and and that's the way
the most effective politicians have
tapped into our feelings with Obama it
was our sense of hope and with Trump
maybe something more powerful he tapped
into our fears and our rage and he gave
us a place to put it and that place was
each other and it's very powerful to
have a divided nation they want us
divide it because we're easily
controlled that way and he's in bed with
the oligarchs the people the
billionaires that control [ __ ] so when
you say all the Bernie people in the
Hillary people and they hate each other
and the right hates the left this is all
part of the the oligarchies plan you
don't mean to be a little cynical about
it divide and conquer so we need to try
the best we can to see our that's what I
love about this you do the one thing
that people should do I try to do it
sometimes but I don't have the patience
a practice which is like listen to
people listen to other points of view
and you don't judge them I mean you go
down there and the first one and talk to
these other crab fishermen I think in
Louisiana okay and I love you they're
not watching this no they're not
watching
but but maybe you could help them steal
HBO anyway they're not rednecks I mean
they're there what right no I didn't
strike me that way they were very
liberal on the gay marriage issue mm-hmm
and and you're very understanding
they're all Trump voters because they
want to change the information Oh their
insurance yes the one place where I have
to push back and but the facts thing is
like okay they didn't like Obama and
they want Trump but they don't really
know where they're getting their health
insurance which you think is such a
personal issue that that's one you could
get right that's that's where it be very
hard not for me to yell at them we were
not to say anything right I mean I kind
of was like but you know I left them
open you know and people I mean I was
there are facts and the facts are they
got their insurance from the guy who
they hate and then they voted for the
guy who's gonna take it away from them I
know that's so I know people feel stupid
even with true things I know I know it's
an impossible
[Applause]
getting people's porky pine needles down
right you know which is I think what I
mean is defenses but I think of it more
visually like that which which happens
more in the first hug hello
then when with a big argument from a
smarty pants me okay she goes in there
with love she does the people it's
amazing that disagree that she disagrees
with but that goes so much further to
getting them to listen maybe to a fact
or two down the road and they'll say you
know that that woman that was here yet
she said the way she was with us and now
she's saying this we should listen to
her they have never met a Jew right no
they had never they had to Google Jew
anything they did wrong there weren't
Jews there right is Eskimo a racist word
no and that's Jesus Christ okay let's
get into it
let's okay so no I think we're both on
the same page there they're words that
we both used to use all comedians did
10-15 years ago and we don't use them
anymore because we don't need them they
didn't surely you're more we're more
creative we can think of other words to
say besides that's so gay right right
sure okay
ten years from now we'll look back on
this show and go it can you believe we
said XY and Z and that's okay but you
can take it too far don't you think the
things I mean your you love Steve Martin
right okay no yes I'm show a little bit
of the King Tut thing because I want to
okay they objected to this at Reed
College Reed College what you know the
college right did this this is racist
and well they said that they said it's
like making a song just littered with
the n-word everywhere the Egyptian garb
is racist as well the gold face of the
saxophone denser is an exhibition of
blackface its King Tut it's a bit it's
Steve Martin I don't have the answer but
I will say a couple of things one I'm
trying very hard not to roll my eyes at
the youth at our youth being progressive
because they tend to be on the right
side of history to whatever you iLook
worship Steve Martin I hold him no
account to this whatever but we also
know that comedy what's great about it
and what's frustrating about it is that
it is not evergreen there are things
I've said in my concert that's the same
movie held against me you know but that
I don't stand about that I'm embarrassed
but when he did that bit King Tut was
seventeen hundred and thirty-two years
old and seventeen years old so that
forty years has it really I don't think
that Egyptians